Hey guys, as you may know, i did a tedx talk in the summer about my experience with
the lion diet, the all meat diet that put my autoimmune disorder that caused crippling
arthritis and gave me two joint replacements into remission. I followed Tedx's guidelines
very carefully, as i'm aware my experience with diet is anecdotal. I finished the
talk asking the medical system to look into the diet further. We spent the last four
months going back and forth with tedx because they won't post the talk. I was the
only talk from that tedx conference that they refused to post. They said my talk
went against their community guidelines, but couldn't name exactly what it went against,
and it didn't. Like i said, i was really careful. Since then, harvard has put out
a study on the carnivore diet that i've linked below showing other people who have
also had success putting their diseases into remission. This is something that should
be taken seriously and looked into. Tedx is supposed to be a place for new ideas
and novel thinking and anecdotal reports. They have tons of vegan talks claiming
veganism cures diseases. But my story didn't make it through because it violated
community guidelines they can't name so i decided to put it up here. Enjoy. Hi, my
name is Mikhaila Peterson and i'm here to talk about how i put my idiopathic autoimmune
disorder and mood disorder and chronic fatigue into remission with an extreme elimination
diet of only eating meat. But i will start at the beginning. When i was two, i started
walking with my feet out like a duck and by the time i was in grade 2, i was walking
down stairs one foot at a time complaining that my shoes were too small and i was
diagnosed with juvenile rheumatoid arthritis active in 37 joints.
I was put on methotrexate and naproxen to get my symptoms under control and had cortisone
injected into 17 of my joints. In grade 2 i was sitting on a chair in class because
i couldn't sit on the carpet because i couldn't sit on my knees or cross my legs.
I was using this really ugly fat pencil because i couldn't hold a pencil because i couldn't close my hand.
When i was in grade 4, i was put on enbrel, a biologic immune suppressant and i started
injecting myself with enbrel and methotrexate twice a week and i was put into a medically
induced remission and i went on all the sports teams i could go on. I went from being
nearly wheelchair bound to playing sports. At the same time my mental health declined
dramatically and i started experiencing OCD symptoms and suicidal thoughts and i
was put on SSRIs and diagnosed with major depressive disorder potentially bipolar type 2 with hypomania.
When i was in grade 8, i started experiencing the sensations of mosquitoes biting my whole body.
And chronic fatigue. And by chronic fatigue, I mean I couldn't wake up and i was falling asleep in class.
By the time i was in grade 11, my arthritis had gotten bad enough that it had destroyed
all the cartilage in my right hip and i stopped being able to sleep because of the
pain and was put on oxycontin. And when i was 17, i had my hip replaced.
While i was healing from my hip replacement, my body destroyed all the cartilage in
my left ankle and i ended up walking on basically broken bones.
So i had my ankle replaced, so that was 17.
I went off to university and my mental health deteriorated further. They tried to
stabilize me with wellbutrin and i ended up having a grand mal seizure at the university
library. They tried to stabilize me with an SNRI and i was so angry i felt like i
could claw my skin off. But a year and a half into university (this gets better, i swear) about a year and a half...
About a year and a half into university, I was so fatigued that i missed my final exams and i dropped out and went home.
When i got home, i started experiencing a rash on my back and on my bum and then on
my face and when i got to my face i thought, okay arthritis is one thing,
Idiopathic hypersomnia or chronic fatigue is one thing,Chronic depression is one
thing,but like a rash on my face? I cannot handle that and i started researching.
December 2014, the rash stopped healing!
And i went to dermatologist after dermatologist and they said, you know, stop doing
this. You're anxious. I was like, okay, that's not super helpful.
So i figured if i don't figure out what's wrong with me, i'm going to die because
my body was destroying its tissues. At that point i was on tylenol 3 to take at night
because the shoulder pain was so bad from the arthritis that wasn't kept in check
that i couldn't sleep. I was taking 40 milligrams of adderall just to wake up in
the morning, because of the ideopathic hypersomnia, i was taking dapsone, which is
used in antibiotic use to treat leprosy so that my skin would heal. I was taking
40 milligrams of Escitalopram for the depression. I was taking an inhaler because
if i got a cold, it would turn into bronchitis that would turn into pneumonia. And
I'd end up in the hospital because of the immune suppressants. I was taking a prescription-strength
antihistamine because i was so allergic to trees and grass that i was verging on
anaphylaxis in the spring. Anyway there were more. So i started researching and i
came across this rash eventually called dermatitis herpetiformis, which is the skin
manifestation of celiac disease, which is an autoimmune disorder that can be triggered
by gluten. And i thought, holy shit is it celiac disease the whole time? so i cut
out gluten. I went off of my immune suppressants, which weren't really working anyway
given the fact i'd lost a hip and ankle and i started monitoring my symptoms really
closely to look for flare-ups. In september 2015 i reduced my diet further because
cutting out gluten wasn't enough and i thought if i'm going to be doing this for
the rest of my life, researching, trying to figure out what's wrong with me, i might
as well rule out diet. So i went down to meat and greens and certain root vegetables
that i didn't really like, like carrots, sweet potatoes, parsnips. I cut out all
the foods that i thought could be potentially causing inflammation. And that month,
my skin healed for the first time in a number of years. I lost three pant sizes of bloating I didn't know i had.
Two months into that, my fatigue went away for the first time since grade 8 and i
stopped taking adderall. Three months into that diet, my depression went away for
the first time in my entire life and i went from living in hell to being in heaven
a hell that i didn't know i'd been living in.
And i thought, okay, well, i'm not taking any drugs ever again and i stopped taking
my SSRI over a two-week period without realizing - because nobody told me - that
SSRI withdrawal exists. And for the next two years, i had the most horrifying experiences
of my entire life and that is saying something.
I reintroduced soy a couple of weeks after i went off of SSRIs and i had a full-blown autoimmune response.
And it started with my digestion was upset. My entire body got itchy. The next day
my depression was back worse than i'd ever experienced. I got into the shower and
thought, how could i be so arrogant as to think i could control this disease with
diet? and i cried. Four days later i had mouth ulcers. My arthritis was back, my
rash was back and i got my brother to drive me home from my parents
because i didn't think i could drive. And i got out of the car and i went to my apartment.
I turned around and my brothers head looked like that for about 2 seconds he looked
at me and he went off and then it was my brother again and i thought, oh my god i
just stop taking all my medications and now i'm insane.
So for the next year i went in and out of what i now know was SSRI withdrawal mixed
with an autoimmune disorder and food sensitivities. And i had 24-day-long reactions
each time i tried to reintroduce a food.
About a year after that, i figured maybe i'll just stop reintroducing foods and not
experience this. And at that time, i got pregnant, which i didn't even know i would
be able to do, given all the medications i've been on.
I went down to meat and greens to try and get my symptoms under control and a year
after that that i was breastfeeding, getting out of bed. My wrist buckled. I thought,
okay i have to do something because i'm worried i'm going to drop my baby. The arthritis
was back, i was itchy everywhere and i was like, how is this possible? if i'd experienced
remission, why isn't that diet working anymore? and i cut everything out except for beef.
And two weeks after doing that, thinking i'm nuts and hopefully i don't get vitamin deficiencies,
the itch went away and my joints started to feel better.
Four weeks after that, so six weeks after an all-beef diet, the depression lifted
and i stopped crying in the morning and five months after that, the anxiety lifted
and i was back in what i felt was heaven compared to how i'd been living. So that's
all beef, all lamb, salt, and water. Now i've been talking about this diet, to spread
awareness in hopes that the medical community can take something like this seriously.
My mom went on the diet and her osteoarthritis went away. My dad went on the diet
and he lost 70 pounds. His GERDs went away, he had psoriasis that went away. I've
talked to thousands of people with autoimmune disorders who have done similar things and seen similar results.
So that is me now and that is my kid. I'm a CEO, i'm a podcaster. I try to share my
experience to get people to see what this kind of diet does for me. I called it The
Lion Diet because it's not cool to be this restricted and it's not cool to have an
autoimmune disorder. And people who are sick feel isolated and miserable. So i'm
trying to make it cool. But what would be really cool would be if the medical community
could take this seriously and do some case studies.
That's it.